So we're done with lesson one, right?
So if this is our student, she is now
at IT and at the end of lesson one.
What I do is I just want to take
all of this thing together and
not focus too much on lesson
one anymore, if that's okay?
>> Yeah, we can move lesson two over.
>> Okay.
Let's say all of this is lesson two.
What should be some of
the big ideas in lesson two?
>> Well, I think we can
split it up into two parts.
>> Okay.
>> And what do you think we
should do for the first part?
>> Well, right here we should add
some interactivity to the app, right?
So, say there's a button on our app,
you press the button,
boom, something happens.
>> Yeah, that sounds good.
And then in the second part we can
go into details of what exactly is
happening and
also learn about variables and methods.
>> So all of the technical jargon
that sounds like magic right now, but
will not be magic at
the end of this lesson.
>> Exactly.
And we can do this by
building up the new app.
>> Wait, what?
We're making a new app in lesson two?
>> Yeah,
it's going to be a coffee ordering app.
>> Wait, can we call it just Java?
>> Okay, I get it.
>> [LAUGH]
>> [LAUGH].
Yes, let's get started.